silencieux non polluantes
ces bus à hydrogène incarne l'avenir des
transports en commun en expérimentation
dans le département ils ont été conçus
par air liquide russe evrogen en fait
est un bus électrique avec une batterie
qui est plus faible sur les bus
électriques normaux donc 24 kilowatts
une batterie qui est plus petit en
kilowatts kenzo est par exemple et qu'il
bellissime pile à combustible qui charge
cette batterie dès que celle ci descend
en dessous de 50% de charge grâce à cinq
bouteilles d'hydrogène situées sur le
toit le bus garé d'une autonomie de 300
km la recharge s'effectue en 20 minutes
dans une borne située aux loges en josas
un moyen de transport plus écologique
donc mais aussi plus agréable à conduire
ça se conduit pas parce qu'on est pareil
sauf que c'est silencieux ils ont pour
nom d'amour et ça c'est assez
appréciable et puis je pense que à long
terme en fin de service je pense que je
serai beaucoup moins fatigués par
rapport au bruit parasite pour aia qui
pouvait y avoir dans les hautes études
et en cas de réussite de ce test
l'objectif sera de déployer ses moyens
de transport sur tout le territoire
francilien
mon objectif à court terme et ce sera
l'objet d'une délibération convoitera en
novembre au conseil régional c'est de
déployer des territoires à hydrogène des
territoires à hydrogène en ile de france
qui sont des territoires test je pense
que naturellement autour d'orly il ya
quelque chose à faire naturellement ici
autour de du centre de recherche de
l'air liquide et quelque chose à faire
mais on peut identifier
en ile-de-france un certain nombre de
territoires dans lequel on va déployer
des réseaux de bus et de gênes déployés
aussi des flottes de véhicules à
hydrogène avec les entreprises autour de
stations à hydrogène c'est ça notre
priorité
seul hic de ces nouveaux bus leurs prix
alors qu'un véhicule diesel coûte
environ 250000 euros
le bus à hydrogène est estimé à 850
mille euros